we're hearing reports of an explosion at
Brussels Airport I heard two very very
loud explosions I could feel the burn
the building move
[Music]
certainly seemed that Brussels Airport
has been targeted in a terrorist attack
more breaking news we're hearing now
that there has been an explosion at a
brussels metro station close to the EU
[Music]
body emergency exit 7th armored please a
[Music]
terror attack unfolding live on TV sky
correspondent Alex Rossi had just
checked in for his flight home
[Music]
they were right two explosions inside
the departure lounge Belgium had been
raced warnings had been issued but
nothing can prepare you for this
outside the airport sheer panic
the explosions and travel is running for
their lives and inside the terminal
before horror was becoming milk this is
where the explosives were getting
what it was a top bosses terrorist
will attacking much more time many times
or
[Music]
the zoetrope can also do nothing
the walking wounded will led away by
those who could tended to by travelers
as they waited for ambulances to arrive
one gunshot afterwards and there was one
man who was speaking Arabic afterwards
and I heard boom an enormous explosion
after people and I said to myself I'll
try to save more people smoke water
dripping from the ceiling where to walk
through puddles and we were evacuated
[Music]
everything is Zach and I see when I go
out I see all the a lot of people with
blood and I just go does this run out we
have a big bank everybody cried and came
along here you so kind of smoke you know
[Applause]
[Music]
two people with heads like covered
really coveted lots and lots of people
whose hands were covered in blood
with details of the attack on the
International Airport's still emerging
news of more carnage another transport
target during rush hour designed to
cause maximum loss of life underground
terrified passengers were evacuated from
their train and led through the darkness
and the smoke to safety
Malbec metro station is just a few
streets away from the European Union
headquarters the terrorists had sent a
clear message to the West
I was getting off a metro station in
Auckland we heard a loud muffled sort
some panic panic set in
some people started to Russia the metro
station very quickly and we were met by
soldiers at the top of the stairs who
immediately evacuated the place
russell's was now dealing with two major
terrorist attacks coordinated to bring
panic confusion and fear the city's
transport network had ground to a halt
people were urged to stay at home until
the situation had been brought under
control schools were warned to keep
their children indoors the capital was
in lockdown as soon as you can if you'll
get move on and show them first before
the process with hundreds of
international flights canceled the
stranded and disorientated passengers
could do little
separated from their belongings stranded
in a country at war don't muffled so I
knew we were not very close to it but we
were close enough that it reverberating
throughout our entire bodies everybody
running the building should suddenly
late into the afternoon a huge
breakthrough in the hunt for the Bombers
this picture a still frame grabbed from
CCTV footage inside the airport could
identify the killers at first glance it
looks innocuous enough three young men
striding casually through an airport but
it's believed these men weren't
preparing for a holiday they were
preparing for mass murder look carefully
at the single gloves worn on the left
hand of each of the men dressed in black
some experts speculate these gloves
could hide the detonators or the
triggers to the explosives wired to each
suicide bomber the third man probably an
accomplice is now on the run he's
Belgium's most wanted of the roof
thermal vans Aventine mr. in photo
enormous endeavor dr. manaan there is a
photo of three suspects that was taken
in Zaventem two of those seem to have
committed a suicide attack the other one
is wearing a hat and he's being searched
for word various departments and experts
are currently at various crime scene
this will happen for many hours to come
due to the violence of the attacks this
investigations that is particularly
the arrests last week of Abdul Abdul
Salam in a Belgium suburb was greeted
with joy and tempered with disquiet
Europe's most wanted the chief suspect
of the Paris attacks he had been
sheltered and protected this prompted
fears of an extended jihadi network not
one cell but many all linked to Isis the
group is claiming it's behind the
carnage in Brussels and it's shown it
reaches deep inside this country
Belgium's war is not over